e hoje eu vou falar de um tema difícil
mas também muito importante que é
vulnerabilidade um tempo difícil hein
e eu vou levar vocês agora frase uma
frase diz assim vou ler habilidade não é
fraqueza ea incerteza os riscos ea
exposição emocional que enfrentamos
todos os dias não profissionais essa
frase é da pesquisadora brene brown que
pesquisa vulnerabilidade faz parte um
livros dela e eu conheci o trabalho da
bruna ele no médico quando assisti a
palestra dela é o achei que algoritmos
comentava comigo sabe eu não consegui
entender exatamente do que ela estava
falando e bom quem diria né que algum
tempo depois eu ia ficar aqui
conversando com você sobre esse assunto
entendendo plenamente o que o que bonner
habilidade quer dizer na minha vida
nesse momento eu tô bravo e eu tô
grávida durante uma quando ia para
muitas pessoas esse é o pior cenário
contigo para ficar grávida
a mais durante o processo da gravidez eu
percebi que esse é um momento único na
minha vida né por mais que eu tenho em
outros filho o grave de outras vezes
essa minha primeira grávida aí e esse
momento não vai aguentar né eu perceber
que essa é uma chance única de ver esse
momento e como uma decisão eu decidi que
eu passarei por este momento da forma
mais leve possível que eu faria dele um
momento feliz essa decisão não foi fácil
parece eu fico parecendo uma louca
falando aqui felicidade no meio de tudo
que tá acontecendo mas a verdade é que
eu não tive outra opção na eu precisei
abraçar me arrumar habilidade e buscar
ser uma pessoa otimista no meio de jesus
está acontecendo
e quando eu falo de otimismo é porque eu
costumo dizer todo mundo que me conhece
sabe que eu digo que eu sou uma pessoa
otimista incurável porque é muito
importante que a gente consiga em
momentos difíceis como ele que a gente
avisando agora onde a gente sente muito
medo muita ansiedade tempo inteiro onde
a gente tá vivendo experimentando
emoções muito difícil utilizávamos a
tristeza frustração que a gente consiga
manter um pouquinho de felicidade um
pouquinho de otimismo a segunda nosso
coração itaú e eu sei que é difícil
porque eu estou vivendo esse momento e
para mim a gravidez é um momento na vida
de todo mundo onde a gente fica muito
mais vulnerável do que o normal né gente
sente mais vulnerável porque a gente
passa por um contato mais próximo com a
dívida com a morte tudo pode acontecer
durante uma gravidez mas é isso
e nem fazer isso da maneira mais larga
que eu pudesse né não só para mim eu
acho que para todo mundo está precisando
nesse momento nasceu o rei durante uma
pandemia todo mundo castelo com
processos que tal ciclos naturais da
nossa vida mas neste momento está sendo
muito mais difícil passar por esse
processo de vida de uma porque
totalmente porque a gente já tendo que
passar por esses momentos mundo mais
sozinhos né os hospitais estão mudando
os protocolos a gente não pode mais
receber visita a gente não pode abraçar
as pessoas que a gente ama a gente não
pode mais chorar e nem ruim junto com as
pessoas que a gente ama então esses
momentos que já são momentos muito
intensos cigarro ainda mais é difícil de
lidar porque a gente tá passando por
isso de uma maneira muito solitária mas
não é exatamente disso que eu tô falando
né não é exatamente disso que alguém me
falar eu vou contar o episódio para
vocês como é que foi que eu me
a questão da mulher habilidade outro dia
eu tava aqui em casa dizendo minha vida
e aí de repente rolou uma mudança neste
protocolo de saúde de atenção à gestante
hospital onde eu tô com a região do meu
quarto e aí eu tive uma crise de
ansiedade o hospital decidiu que o que a
equipe que vai me atender no parque não
o dia mais entrar e eu quis esperar em
pânico e aí fui tomar um banho para
tampar clarear minhas ideias e durante o
banho daí um pensamento na minha cabeça
eu tava com medo do meu quarto não vai
acontecer e aí eu fiquei pensando bem o
que que eu preciso para aquele espaço
aconteça eu preciso de um bebê que eu
tenho aqui tá bem tá saudável e eu
preciso do meu próprio corpo né eu não
tenho como resolver nascer empurrar de
volta então eu percebi durante esse
banho tentando acalmar aqui independente
do que eu faça eu não tenho controle
sobre os processos da natureza né
e eu não sou maior do que a natureza e
aí mesmo eu não entendia dimensão da
vulnerabilidade na minha vida nesse
momento que embora as coisas não possam
estar no meu controle mas eu percebi que
vai acontecer o que tiver que acontecer
comigo então fica natureza é mais do que
eu te faço e tenho chance uma pessoa
humana vulnerável e que pode acontecer
muita coisa comigo mas está tudo bem né
o que este é o último de vazio né deixa
o sinônimo de debate na terra e aí eu
sei que situação muito grave né
especialmente eu estou grávida e tenho
acompanhado as questões saúde mais de
perto justamente por ser grupo dinâmico
eu sei que tem muita coisa aconteceu eu
sei que a situação é muito grave e exige
que a gente tomem as precauções
necessárias mais ele também entende que
para além do medo e da frustração da
tristeza tem
tá acontecendo hoje o tempo né tem muito
sentimento eu não sei vocês mas eu não
tenho muito assim dizendo tudo mais
linda no dia então o dentro de mim tem
muita vida acontecendo né com esse bebê
dentro do meu coração dentro da minha
cabeça com muitas emoções então eu me
conectei com a ideia de que de fato ou
amanhã ele é uma grande é certeza ele é
uma grande incerteza e muito de nós por
se conectar justamente com essa coisa
aprendizado a gente não sabe se vai
estar aqui amanhã como vai ser a gente
não tem o controle das coisas a gente
fica aproximou dos nossos familiares
amigos a gente tá aqui hoje fazendo esse
perde para muita gente que não poderia
estar se ele pode presencial então eles
momento também então chama muitas coisas
bonitas para gente né proporcionou muita
coisa misturada é
oi tá tudo misturado
e eu tô falando aqui para gente ocultar
o sentimento de tristeza deixar o luto
de lado né porque quando de nós só
perdendo pessoas eu não tô querendo
dizer que a gente abafar o nosso medo o
que eu tô querendo dizer é que esse
momento também está profissional uma
redefinição dos nossos valores né a
gente faça parte longo de quem a gente
ama a gente tá sentindo falta de coisas
que eu então a gente tinha acesso de
maneira muito fácil de um puxão nada né
poder olhar no olho de alguém que a
gente ama ouvir a voz da pessoa isso não
puxa o real e a verdade é que as
experiências agora elas valem muito mais
eu brinco que o nosso mercado de ação do
nosso mercado de ação do nosso coração
charme muito quando eu olhar no olho e
te abraçar agora vale as ações
criticaram o valor das ações criticavam
ah que bom depois disso tudo aqui que eu
já falei para vocês eu vou me
encaminhando para o final e queria fazer
um convite não é porque acho que no meio
disso tudo que está acontecendo aqui a
gente não consegue muito distinguir o
que é medo o que é felicidade as coisas
falando confuso hein eu queria fazer
esse convite né pra gente permitir que a
felicidade também admitir o meio desse
sentimento de destas emoções que a gente
está sentindo tudo ao mesmo tempo muito
identificados né que a gente possa viver
esse momento que a gente ir tá passando
agora é com profundidade a gente não
negue na água que está acontecendo quer
dizer que abrace essa vulnerabilidade
que a gente também tem missa e com o
vídeo a felicidade para fazer parte dos
momentos que a gente tá vivendo porque
eles não voltam né e aí
é basicamente gestar uma vida né que é o
que eu tô fazendo aqui eu estou de 8
meses de gestação é já está muitos
sonhos para o futuro e eu acho que o meu
maior porém para nossa coletividade
nefro a humanidade como um todo é que a
gente se permita aprender com os momento
né que a gente precisa aprender a lidar
com a vulnerabilidade ele dá para falta
de controle né porque ela não é uma vila
na verdade ela não desconecta de verdade
que está acontecendo com os meus
presentes e faz agente viver esse
presente muito mais urgência então eu
separei aqui uma uma frase do encontrei
na que pelo pensador indígena com quem é
o último eu tenho maior admiração pelo
carenagem e ele escreveu uma frase neste
último livro que diz assim
e não saberemos estaremos vivos amanhã
temos de parar de vender o amanhã
ah que bom eu espero que vocês sintam
contaminado a convidar felicidade de
entrar na vida de vocês nesse momento e
também abraçar a vulnerabilidade que a
gente tá vivendo nesse momento tão
difícil recebi um daí o meu abraço e que
a gente consiga flui por essa vida com
um pouquinho mais de leveza muito
obrigado a